Mag das jemand? Weil ich glaube, gewisse Dinge werden einfach immer und immer wieder gemacht, weil man denkt, ja, irgendjemand würde das schon mögen, so Paul, alle, Paul, Paul, das meine ich wirklich ernst, das haben wir immer schon gemacht, genau, hat mal jemand versucht, so lange stehen zu bleiben, wie das versteht, ja, Athezel, Remoulade, oh, aber vergessen hat keine Artischocke, du musst sofort drauf gefasst sein. Idee. Antizipieren ist immer die Lösung. Ja, herzlich willkommen, dass ihr da seid nach diesem fantastischen Intro aus unserer Schlaganfalls-Folge. Falls ihr sie verpasst habt, noch hier ein kleiner Zusammenschnitt von Björn 13. Vielen Dank. Moment. Björn 13? Richtig, Björn 13. Weil du es so benannt hast, weil es der 13. Björn war? Wir sind mittlerweile bei 13 Björns angekommen.
Kein Tim, kein Max, aber 13 Björns. Alle Björns könnten ein satanistisches Ritual vollführen, indem sie sich zu 13 treffen in einem dunklen Keller. Vielen, vielen Dank an Björn, aber natürlich auch vielen, vielen Dank an unseren Gesprächspartner heute. Es ist Stefan Tietze, hallo. Vielen Dank auch an dich, Flo und den Will fürs Erscheinen. Gerne. Willkommen aus dem Urlaub. Wir sind beide braun gebrannt und wohlgenährt. Kommen wir aus dem Urlaub zurück, um uns hier wieder zu treffen, um einen Podcast aufzunehmen. Ich habe es vermisst. Ich habe es auch vermisst. Stefan war in der weiten Welt, hat tagelang durch Gebirge geträngt, hat sich selber gefunden, hat andere Kulturen entdeckt, war mit guten Freunden unterwegs, wirklich mal tiefe Gespräche geführt unterm Sternenhimmel. Ich war am See mit Kumpeln und hab dir erst gespielt. Also alles wie immer. Stellt euch auf eine sehr unangenehme Folge ein, in der Stefan uns über die herrlichen Kulturen dieser Welt erleuchtet und was er nicht alles gefunden hat in diesen Schluchten und wie schön sein Urlaub. Ja, und wie schön Florentin wieder Pokémon durchgespielt hat. Also freut euch auf die ganzen aufgewärmten, lauwarmen Gags. Okay, so gehen wir rein in die neue ... Okay, ja gut, na ja, du bist ... Ich hab die Schärfe nicht reingebracht. Sag mal, ich hab über den Urlaub dich schon ein bisschen vermisst, um ehrlich zu sein, ist relativ schnell erloschen jetzt gleich wieder. Naja, die Schärfe kam ja jetzt gerade von ... Die Schärfe startete durchaus schon vor der Aufnahme. Naja, also du kommst hier rein, hast gesagt, oh, haben wir uns gefunden. Das war dein erster Satz, den sie mir gesagt hat. Da hab ich jetzt gedacht, weiss ich nicht, ob das brauche. Ja, weil du hier wirklich in einem komplett... Ja, der Poncho. Ja, in einem komplett neuer Aufzug hier stehst. Du hast einen Ohrring. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was das alles... Ich habe hier eine Alpaka-Decke besorgt. Das ist nett, aber ich bin brutals allergisch mit dem Decken im Allgemeinen. Ist jemand, ach so, ich dachte, Alpaka... Ist jemand gegen Alpaka-Allergisch? Bestimmt, auf jeden Fall. Das finde ich mal eine gute Frage. Naja, ich war ja in Peru und da gibt es ja viel. Also, was mir vor allem, um dich kurz abzuholen, aufgefallen ist, sowohl das eigene Nacherzählen, das Nacherzählen von eigenen Träumen als auch von eigenen Reisen ist nur für die Person, die erzählt. Ich glaube, das Schlimmste, was man machen kann, ist ein Traum einer Reise. Wenn man eine Reise geträumt hat und das nacherzählt, da muss man schon gut befreundet sein. Wenn man eine schlechte Reise geträumt hat, wo man immer nur zwei von fünf Sternen bei Holidaycheck geht, dann, das interessiert glaube ich niemanden. Ich glaube, die langweiligsten Anekdoten sind die, meine Reise war unerwartet schwer. Das ist schwierig, weil das ist für die betreffende Person super traumatisch und schrecklich. Für die andere Person, es interessiert mich nicht. Dann sass ich drei Stunden im ICE und die Klimaanlage war aus und dann mussten wir noch in Hagen halten und dann waren ja die Leute in die Hälfte ausgestiegen und wollten rauchen, dann konnten wir nicht weiterfahren auf der anderen Seite. Oh, ich dachte gerade, wenn du das so erzählst, denke ich mir, eine unerwartete gute Reise ist fast noch langweiliger. Das stimmt, ja. Also in aller Ausführlichkeit zu erzählen, wie man weiss, wie man es auch will. Moment mal, du hattest einen Sitzplatz reserviert und du konntest dort sitzen.
Ja, ja, und da saß auch niemand, ich kann mich einfach hinsetzen.
Ich cancel alle Termine heute, erzähl mir mehr.
Ja genau, das Bordbistro war auch funktioniert.
Was?
Weil das hat ja gar keine Nachrichtenwert. Diese Geschichte ist noch langweiliger.
Aber das ist jetzt eine neue Regel, wir erzählen Urlaube nicht nach und Träume nicht nach.
Okay, gut. Gut. Und ich... Hm, nee, nee, nichts. Das war doch ein Traum. Sorry. Nee, es war sehr schön. Ich freue mich aber auch, hier zurzeit zu sein. Das freut mich. Während du in Peru warst, habe ich ein kleines Lied geschrieben. Ah, okay. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Das Land ist mir morgsegal. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Ne, der Beat ist schon falsch. Das ganze Land ist eine Qual. Ach so, du brauchst diesen. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Das Land ist mir morgsegal. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Das ganze Land ist eine Qual. Nice, schön. Aber auch gut, dass immer alle Songs, die du singst, organisch von dir kommen, immer Schlager sind.
Das stimmt, ich habe eine natürliche Tendenz, Aszendenz, Schlager. Ja genau, und es ist einfach alles da reingehen. Ja und du sagst doch immer, dass du noch nicht die Musik gefunden hast, die dir gefällt. Ja genau. Vielleicht ist es Schlager. Das kann auch sein. Aber dieses Land, glaube ich, ist auch aufgrund dieses Klavenbeats kein Land für dich. Schrecklich. Ne, ich hab das Gefühl, ich muss gar nicht nach Peru fahren, weil ich diesen Beat einfach schon 24, 7, vor allem 3 Uhr nachts bei mir gegenüber in der Kneipe habe. Deswegen habe ich da gar kein Bedürfnis, dahin zu fahren. Ist es denn eine spanische Kneipe? Äthike, vorte, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich spreche selber kein Spanisch, aber schwierig. Aber du hast, du warst auf Machu Picchu, um es einfach mal ganz kurz abzukürzen. Machu Picchu, ist das ein Gagname oder ist das, heißt das, was heißt das? Weil es ist ein viel zu schmissiger Name, weil du hast die Pyramiden von Gize, Kolos, die hängenden Gärten, wobei man muss sagen, der Koloss von Rodos, die, geil, wenn wir einen Ort brauchen für unseren Koloss, dann doch bitte Rodos. Ja, Rhodos oder Athen? Nee, nee, nee. Eulen nach Athen, Koloss nach Rhodos. Easy, next. Braten nach Athen und Koloss nach Rhodos. So, das haben die damals im römischen Senat beschlossen einfach. So machen wir das. Wir reimen. Also der Koloss von Rhodos ist perfekt. Machu Picchu kommt dabei direkt dahinter her. Machu Picchu ist super. Ich kann es nicht mehr hören. Und das heisst, da ist ein Völkermord begangen und deswegen wurde der danach benannt oder irgendwie sowas? Nehm ich mal an. Es heisst, es ist, glaube ich, Quechua die Sprache und heisst der Alte Berg. Warum ist gerade der jetzt alt? Also ist der älter als alle anderen? Älter als der junge Berg, der daneben steht. Der heisst irgendwie Pack-Tum-Patschum.
Der grosse Müllberg, wo die ganzen Verpackungen von den ganzen Bonbons liegen. Von den ganzen sechstausend, in Klammern ausrufezeichen, Touristen, die da jeden Tag hinströmen. Ja, das stimmt. Ist es nicht auch so der Gag, dass diese Touristenberge immer grösser werden, weil Müll sich aufsammelt? Kann gut sein. Und dann sozusagen die Grössen noch grösser werden? Ist das nicht ein schönes Bild auch für Gier? Ich glaube, die Touristen tragen den Berg auch langsam ab, weil die da so drüber labern und Lawinen auslösen und Steine in die Taschen stecken. Deswegen, glaube ich, tragen die den Berg ab, aber daneben entsteht ein neuer Berg, der Müllberg. Du bist ja im Bus hochgefahren, ne? Ich bin mit dem Bus hochgefahren, ja. Das Problem war, das war mega, dass du mich, dass du mich so outcalls direkt. Da war ja nicht zu übersehen deine Instagram-Stories. Okay, also die Schärfe lässt nicht nach. Es hat sehr doll geregnet am Morgen, wo ich da hoch bin. Wir sind an meinem Geburtstag hoch, das war ein tolles Geschenk. Alles Gute zum Geburtstag, nachträglich, Stefan. Es kam ja auch keine Nachricht oder so. Und es war sehr doll am Regnen, so doll, dass wir mit dem Bus hochfahren mussten und dann zurück sind wir gelaufen. Und beim Rückweg habe ich gedacht, Gott sei Dank sind wir nicht hochgelaufen, weil super ätzend auch scheiß Wege. Also die Inka, toll, tolle Leistung, ach, ach eine was so tolle Leistung, aber die Treppen haben sich richtig scheiße gebaut. Die sind immer so ein bisschen zu hoch. Treppen konnten die nicht. Dass du eigentlich jede zweite Stufe stolperst. Eine Norm. Ja, warum halten die sich nicht an die EU-Norm? Die halten sich an die EU-Norm. Also diese Azteken, ey. Aber jetzt weiß ich auch, woher die Norm kommt, weil es ist, nicht genormte Treppen zu laufen, ist unglaublich anstrengend und seltsam. Ja. Aber genau, wir sind runtergelaufen, das war ziemlich anstrengend.
Toll, richtig super, toll gemacht,
liebe Inkas. Was ich nicht
wusste, ist, dass es auch erst, glaube ich,
im 14. oder 15. Jahrhundert gebaut wurde,
Machu Picchu. Ach so.
Was so ein bisschen
kätzerisch gesprochen,
ein bisschen egaler macht. Ja, das war
so das letzte Projekt der Azteken,
bevor sie komplett ausgerottet wurden von Inquisitor. Und da haben sie sich gedacht, das machen wir noch. Ja, man weiß nicht genau, ob das der Rückzugsort war, als dann die Spanier kamen, oder ob das so ein Bau war, oder ob die überhaupt jemals diese Verschwörungstheorie, dass es gar nie bewohnt war, sondern die Conqueredorne, dass man direkt übernt haben. Das ist eine spannende Verschwörungstheorie.
Die Verschwörungstheorie ist viel langweiliger. Ich dachte jetzt so, dass es von Aliens gebaut wurde
oder dass man Kontakt, dass die versucht haben,
in den Weltraum zu fliehen.
Nee, da hat niemand gewohnt.
Wir haben uns aber die Frage gestellt,
was ist eigentlich die langweilige Verschwörungstheorie
in dem Podcast hier?
Ich fände es gut, wenn du jetzt so ein Hardcore-Verschwörungstheoretiker wärst
für genau diese super langweilige Verschwörungstheorie.
Und auf jeder Party, sag mal, habt ihr eigentlich schon mal gehört, dass der Machu Picchu, dieses uralte Bauwerk, ja, ja, eigentlich nie bewohnt wurde? Ja, und alle sind so, ja, okay, aber in den richtigen Kreisen, in den Archäologenkreisen, werde ich sofort so ausgeschlossen, gecancelt. Nicht so schlecht, in so einem sehr speziellen Kreis ist man einfach ungern gesehen, weil man diese Verschwörungstheorie trif trifft. Komm, Stefan glaubt nicht, da ist die Bewohner. Ich höre da raus, dass du auch dich informiert hast und oder eine geführte Führung. Wir hatten einen riesengroßen Reiseführer dabei. Mein Kumpel hatte so einen grossen Lonely Planet dabei. Also ein riesiges... Ach so, ich dachte jetzt, der Mensch war gross, der Reiseführer. Wir hatten einen riesigen Reiseführer. R Riesig gross, aber der hat uns auf den Berg getragen. Wir hatten ein ganz grosses Buch dabei und haben dann nachgeblättert. Im Nachhinein, man wusste nicht genau, wozu denn die Texte jeweils gehören, weil da wurden basically Steine beschrieben die ganze Zeit. Und erst rückblickend haben wir herausgefunden, dass wir oft die falschen Texte an den falschen Steinen vorgelesen haben. Wie dem auch sei, Lirum Larum. Waren Pharaonen drin? Wow, krass, wusste ich gar nicht. Ich dachte, wir sind in Peru, aber gut. Rückblickend war es ein bisschen schwierig, aber... Ja, vor allem, die sehen auch alle gleich aus, die einen sind ein bisschen rechts geschliffen, der anderen sind ein bisschen links geschliffen. Es relativiert so den Urlaub ein bisschen, so, wow, Horizont erweitert, neue Erfahrungen. Nee, nee, ihr hattet den falschen Reiseführer dabei. Ach so. Ja, das, ja, das, okay. Naja, aber wir hatten trotzdem einen schönen Urlaub. Also, klar, die Restaurants, wir haben viel über die mexikanische Kultur gelernt in Peru, aber warum denn nicht? Nee, Peru war cool. Wirklich? Es wäre auf jeden Fall nicht dein Land gewesen. Nee, lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru, passt da ganz gut, nicht nur wegen des Sklavenbeats, sondern vor allem auch wegen der Lautstärke in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln. Oh ja. Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich dein Horror. Es gibt gar kein Ruheabteil und alles ist sozusagen eher so ein Lautabteil. Weil es ist, warum auch immer, gesellschaftlich akzeptiert, dass man auf seinem Handy laut Videos guckt und Musik hört. Und das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen. Und das schlimmste Lautstärkeerlebnis eines öffentlichen Vergessenen habe ich erlebt, da sind wir in einem Collektivo gefahren. Das war so ein privat organisiertes Grossraumtaxi, wo man dann zusammen irgendwo hinfangen kann für wenig Geld. Und da haben wirklich alle zwölf Insassen in diesem kleinen Bus auf ihrem Handy laut TikToks gehört. Und ich saß da hinten drin und dachte mir, das kann nicht wahr sein, weil diese Lautstärke war nicht zu ertragen. Und es war, davor war es nervig, an dem Punkt war es dann einfach nur noch lustig, weil man hat auch gesehen, man kennt das ja von sich selber, man kann nicht aufhören, einen TikTok zu gucken oder so, oder bei dir ist es noch Instagram Reels, glaube ich, aber vor mir sass dann jemand, der hat das bestimmt 15 Mal angeguckt, die sich dieses, war auch toll, so ein peruanisches Pärchen, was getanzt hat, ganz toll, zu so einem, ach okay, das habe ich krass gedacht. Und dann sassen wir da hinten und man kommt und wir haben uns überlegt, wie können wir jetzt zurückschlagen als Europäer? Wie können wir jetzt diesem Schmarrn einmal das Ende bereiten? Und man überlegt, womit kann Europa jetzt nerven? Wie können wir als Europäer jetzt maximal zurücknerven? Und dann haben wir auch unser Handy rausgeholt und haben den Schnelldurchlauf vom Eurovision Song Contest 2021 angemacht, auf voller Lautstärke auf dem Handy. Und ich habe mich kaputt gelacht, weil plötzlich dann dieser Schnelldurchlauf durchs ... Und an keinem Punkt auf der Welt würde ich das machen und wäre nicht wahnsinnig nervös oder fände diesen Gag wahnsinnig unangenehm. Da war es einfach nur wie angemessen, es hat sich fast nicht falsch angefühlt. Und tatsächlich haben einige Leute die Handys ausgemacht, um zu hören, was da denn gerade Merkwürdiges aus der letzten Reihe kommt. Ich finde das so geil, dass das sowohl deine grösste Leidenschaft als auch deine schärfste Waffe ist. Es ist meine schärfste Waffe. Also in jeder Gelegenheit so, okay, hol den ESC. Naja, es sind ja nicht nur die guten Songs, im Schnelldurchlauf sind ja alle Songs, die selbst Montenegro etc. schickt im Rennen und nicht die besten Parts auch und alles live gesungen. Also es hat gewisse Schwierigkeiten, aber das war es, Europa schlug mit dem Schnelldurchlauf des ESCs zurück und hat gewonnen. Ich sage mal, Europa hat mal wieder gewonnen. Ja, selbst Konkurren für Europa. In diesem kleinen, in diesem kleinen Collektivo haben wir gewonnen. Stark, aber selbst da muss Europa sagen, nee, ihr hört jetzt unsere Kulturen. Fuck it, nee. Vergesst mal euren Quatsch hier, wir machen jetzt ESC. Die Spanier waren einfach knallhart. Die haben einfach die Inkerstädte eingenommen und alle deren Gebäude abgerissen und deren größten Tempel benutzt als Fundament für deren grösste Kirchen. Also die Spanier sind da einfach hin und so no bullshit. Das ist ja unvorstellbar, es ist unvorstellbar. Nichts hat hier Wert. Sie sind hingekommen und gesagt, hier hat nichts Wert? Wir bauen unsere Stadt genau dahin, wo eure ist. Wir bauen unsere grössten Kirchen auf eure grössten Kirchen. Nutzen wir Steine von euch? Nein. Das war wirklich insanely zu beobachten. Es blieben ein paar Gebäude noch stehen, weil lustigerweise, es ist nicht lustigerweise, aber die Ironie kommt später, was jetzt kommt, ist nicht lustig, deswegen ist die Überleitung schwierig. Es ist ein sehr Erdbeben getriebenes Land und die ganzen Spanier haben ihre Gebäude gebaut und beim ersten Erdbeben sind alle spanischen Gebäude zusammengefallen und alle Inka-Gebäude sind stehen geblieben. Ach geil. Weil die das drauf hatten. Das war so die kleine Rache. Die Gebäude steht jetzt auch nicht mehr, weil die Spanier den natürlich auch weggeballert haben. Aber das erzählt man sich. Ja, das war Peru. Das war Peru in den Nutsch. Viel spanisches Zeug, es wurde viel Spanisch gesprochen, es wurde laut Musik gehört, es wurden laut Soaps gehört beim Essen. Okay. Also es wird nicht dein Land. Wenn so ein ganzes Land halt das akzeptiert hat, diese Lautstärke, kommt man da nicht mehr raus. Das ist dann wirklich schwer, dann den Anfang zu machen. Da brauchst du wirklich eine Revolution, da müsste halt irgendein europäisches Land nochmal hin und einfach da einfach für Ruhe sorgen. Ich habe schon versucht.
Silencio.
Ich bin als Deutscher nach Peru gereist und habe gesagt, so, der weisse Mann, der grosse weisse Teufel erzählt euch jetzt mal, wie es läuft, nämlich wir hören alle auf, Musik zu hören. Hier sind Kopfhörer, ich bringe sie euch von Übersee. So ganz viele billige Kopfhörer, die haben uns nicht gehört. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Naja, aber ich stand schon auf Kriegsfuß mit dem Land, als ich hingekommen bin und das erste Mal gefragt habe, wie es hier mit dem Trinkgeld ist und es zurückkam, nee, es gibt keine klare Regelung. Oh Gott, mein Gott, auch wenn ihr euch auf Namen einigen könnt, wir sind Peru, dann könnt ihr euch doch auf eine Trinkgeldregelung einigen, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich habe ein großes Problem mit Ländern, wo keine Trinkgeldregelung werden. Ganz schrecklich, ganz schrecklich. So vage Trinkgeldregelung. Das sollte so direkt neben dem Schild sein. You're entering Peru und dann nebendirekt so funktioniert Trinkgeld, einfach so direkt aus dem Weg. Die Fluggesellschaft, wenn man ein Ticket bucht, so, da kommen jetzt auch die Covid-Regularien, schickt doch mit, was die Trinkgeldregularien sind. Hier haben wir so ein kleines, die fünf wichtigsten Fakten zum Land. Und ich will eigentlich so eine große Excel-Tabelle, wo so in Grün, Gelb und Rot die Wageness von Trinkgeldregeln sind. Das ist wenig, das ist Mittel, das ist viel Trinkgeld, damit man selber entscheiden kann. Ich dachte, es gibt rote Länder, wo man nicht hinreisen kann. Weil ich wäre knallhart gewesen. Es gibt einfach so Ausreisewarnungen für Länder, in denen keine kleinen Trinkgeldregeln sind. Glas klar bis sehr vage. Genau, so glasklar, sowas wie Amerika, grün, ganz grün auf der Karte. Ja, da steht es einfach auf dem Preisschild drin. Das steht auch mit drin. Es steht nicht auf dem Preisschild, aber es wird trotzdem verlangt. Genau. Also auf dem Preisschild steht fünf Dollar und es wird verlangt sechs Dollar fünfzig. Und der Europäer denkt, was? Und da, wo es nicht steht, sind knallhart 20 Prozent normal
oder aber, Tipp is included, steht
klar drauf. Also,
grüner wird es nicht, so hellgrün ist
die USA.
Deutschland, schwieriger schon.
Gelb. Ja, ja, ja, schon gelb. Man sagt
zehn Prozent, aber wer gibt denn zehn Prozent bei einer
200-Euro-Rechnung, wenn du mit ganz vielen Leuten essen
gehst? Niemand
gibt dann 20 Euro. Naja, jedenfalls die Gelb-Stefans-Probleme. Wenn du mit vielen Leuten essen gehst. Wenn du für 600 Euro essen gehst, wer gibt denn 60 Euro Trinkgeld, oder? Also ist doch völlig unklar. Stille. Ausser so jemand mit einem Monokel hinten lacht. Köstlich. Stimmt. Die beste Reaktion auf den Stand-Up. Stimmt. Stimmt. Ja, wenn man vielen Leuten essen geht, das meine ich ja nur. Ja, es kommt darauf an, also ich würde bei Deutschland Geld machen mit einem Sternchen, Lieferando oder Lieferdienste. Immer noch unklar, wie ist es mit automatisch abgebuchtem Trinkgeld, kriegen die Leute des Thais ist da dran, hat sie uns versichert.
Na gut, aber sie sind 15 Sachen dran.
Ich weiß nicht, was für sie dran sein bedeutet. Na, das scheint ein großer Coup zu sein. Was heißt für die Gen Z dran sein? Wir wissen es nicht genau, vielleicht ist es auch so ein Slang. Sind die auch dran am Klimawandel, weil dann Prostmahlzeit. Schreibt uns gerne mal, falls ihr jung seid und wenig Geld habt und nicht für 600 Euro essen geht, dann schickt uns mal was dran sein heißt. Ist das so synonym für ich mach's nicht? Das ist so wie, ja ich schau mal ob ich komme. Ich mach's morgen in Ruhe. Ja. Ich mach's nie. Da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich das ... Ich mach's nicht. Nicht.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ja, Peru ist schwierig, aber wie hast du es gehandhabt? War es dann wirklich so ein Mimikspiel, dass du so lange Pesos hingelegt hast, bis der Gegenüber zufrieden gewirkt hat? Ich hab so lange Solace hingelegt, bis das Lächeln grösser wurde. Nee, tatsächlich hab ich das ... Man macht's wohl nicht einfach, ausser mal, wenn der Service besonders gut ist. Also die schrecklichste Regel der Welt. Und vor allem es führt dazu, dass ich immer das Gefühl hatte, Leute sind entweder sauer auf mich oder eigentlich nur sauer. Wenn man Trinke gibt und es ist nicht verlangt, ist es einfach eine weirde Großzügigkeit. Da bin ich mit so einem Kondelismus konfrontiert, irgendwie, ich meine es sei, mein Geld hinz... also merkwürdig, in beide Richtungen merkwürdig. Beides unhöflich, ja. Und diesen Sweetspot habe ich, glaube ich, nie richtig gefunden. Es war eher dann wahrscheinlich normal, wenn man nichts gegeben hat oder sowas. Bei manchen Restaurants habe ich das schon gemacht und dann war es auch okay. Aber merkwürdige Regel und nicht gut gehandhabt. Konntest du dein Spanisch ein bisschen aufriffen? Ja, also es war schlecht vorher, es ist immer noch grandios schlecht und je mehr Trinkgeld man gegeben hat, desto mehr wurde man für meinen Spanisch gelaufen. Sehr gut, du hast es meistens nicht verstanden, aber okay, okay? Also der Tiefpunkt war glaube ich bei einer Taxifahrt, wir müssen immer abgewechseln, wer vorne sitzt und mit dem Fahrer, laut mit dem Fahrer diskutiert. Und einmal habe ich mich nicht drücken können und war dann vorne und es gab einen Cut, wenn man sich einen Vorstellungen schaffen kann. Und am Ende der Fahrt habe ich sein Handy in der Hand gehalten und warum auch immer, ich wollte nur Smalltalk machen, plötzlich ein YouTube-Video angemacht bekommen von einer ... Ich wollte fragen, was sein beliebtes, liebtes, favorite peruanischer Film ist. Und er hat mir ... Am Ende habe ich dann sein Handy in der Hand gehabt und er hat mir eine Inka-Doku auf YouTube angemacht. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es war, damit ich die Klappe halte, ob es das größte Missverständnis der Welt war. Am Ende habe ich so eine Doku auf Spanisch angeschaut. Ich finde das so gut, dass du wie so ein Kleinkind abgefertigt wirst. Einfach so ein laufendes Handy in der Hand. Hier, guck das an, einfach. Okay. Dann habe ich so ein Handy in der Hand gehabt und musste an diese Doku gucken. Da haben mir viele Fragen gestellt, die ich nicht verstanden habe. Hat dir Fragen zur Doku gestellt? Ja, oder weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht auch sonst so. Ich glaube, es war zur Doku, weil ich hätte nebenbei geschaut, und es wäre weird, wenn er das Thema gewechselt hätte, während ich sein Handy in der Hand habe. Das war merkwürdig. Aber sehr viele Leute kennen gelernt, immer schön auf Spanisch gefragt, wie sie heissen und so, und dann kam man immer nett ins Gespräch und so. Stark. Immer so diese drei Fragen, so wo kommst du her, wie heisst du und where is the Tourist Information Bureau und so. In der Bibliotheker. Und dann am Anfang bei der ersten Taxifahrt gehört, wie teuer, also als wir in der einen Stadt waren, wie teuer normalerweise die Taxifahrten sind für Einheimische und wie teuer die für Touristen sind. Und die ziehen einfach Touristen ab, was ja legitim ist. Die Touristen bezahlen ja dann das Geld auch, also es ist ja Angebot und Nachfrage irgendwie auch. Touristen wollen Taxen und bezahlen dann demnach das Geld. Aber seitdem hat sich Taxifahren eigentlich falsch angefühlt, weil man immer wusste, dass man jetzt den Preis bekommt, der niemals ... Du bist immer der Dumme hier. Niemand ist immer der Dumme, man ist immer doof und so. Und dann versucht man zu handeln, dann sagen die nein, dann würden die Touristen da hinten stehen mit gepackten Koffern und auf Deutsch laut fragen, wo das Tourist Information Büro ist.
Das ist doch klar. Und auch eine Erkenntnis, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch so geht im Urlaub, aber man hasst andere Touristen, ist selber aber auch ein Tourist. Man will an Orte, die nicht touristisch sind, will man aber nicht, weil die nicht touristischen Orte sind nicht die Orte, wo du sein willst. Du willst nicht an nicht aufbereiteten Orten sein. Die touristischen Orte sind ja die, wo sich Mitteleuropäer darauf geeinigt haben, dass das die schönen, sehenswerten Orte sind. Da willst du ja sein. Wo man dich auch versteht ein bisschen. Es ist so heuchlerisch. Tourist sein ist so heuchlerisch. Die anderen Touristen führen dir deine eigene Dusseligkeit vor Augen. Du denkst dir so, was für Trottel. Eine eigene Beschränktheit. Und dann fühlt man sich wohl an Orten, die maximal so sind wie zu Hause. Also, wie weit es halt geht in dem Land. Das ist wirklich merkwürdig. Was mir aber auch aufgefallen ist, ich weiß nicht, wie es da auch so geht, aber ich habe das Gefühl, das Gute an Urlaub ist auch, dass man wieder Bock auf seinen Alltag hat. Dass man wieder so Bock auf die ganz normalen Sachen hat. Ich meine nicht auf den Job, sondern auf die langweiligen Sachen im Alltag. Ja genau, so oh und dann gönne ich mir einen Doktor Pepper am Abend, so irgendwie sowas. Solche kleinen Sachen kommen dann wieder. Vielleicht ist das der eigentliche Sinn von Urlaub, dass man danach wieder Lust auf sein normales Leben hat. Das wollte ich dir eigentlich mitbringen, ich wollte dir eigentlich eine Inka-Cola mitbringen. Kennst du die? Das ist nämlich auch inzwischen auch von Coca-Cola geowned, aber wenn du bei McDonald's da in Peru eine Cola bestellst, kriegst du keine Coca-Cola, sondern eine Inca-Cola. Die ist ganz gelb, schmeckt ein bisschen so wie Mountain Dew, super unglaublich scharf, chemisch süss, also eigentlich das, was du total magst. Und das kommt ursprünglich, aber warum jetzt Inca? Ich dachte, Maya haben da gelebt. Nee, nee, nee, Inka haben da gelebt. Du hast gerade Maya. Ich habe Azteken und okay. Du hast Azteken auch noch ins Rennen geworfen. Ach so, sorry, okay. Inka leben da. Wo die Ägypter gerade herkommen, weiß ich gar nicht, aber da haben die Inka geherrscht. Aber du warst auch in Mexiko schon? Da habe ich auch schon. Da gab es Azteken. Maya. Maya. Und wo sind Azteken? Die habe ich noch nicht bereist, deswegen war ich noch nicht. Okay, Maya in Mexiko, Inka in Peru.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, Inka habe ich alles nicht genau verstanden. Und dann, genau, war ich ja bei den Nazca-Linien, weil das hat mich am meisten beeindruckt, die, wo die, ja, sagt man, Schwerungstheorie, Achtung, Ufos gelandet sind früher. Klar, ja. Weil da sind 20 Kilometer lange Linien, teilweise schnurstracksgerade gezeichnet, in die Wüste gezeichnet. Und die Vorstellung ist, dass Ufos wie so ein Flugzeug, so ein Landeanflug und dann unten so ein Fahrwerk rauslassen und dann so gegen den Wind manövrigen, so ja klar. Ja, vor allem die Vorstellung, dass Aliens in Lichtgeschwindigkeit mit für Menschen unvorstellbaren technischen Fähigkeiten durchs Universum flitzen, um dann in Peru, in der Atacama-Wüste auf 20 Kilometer langen, mehr oder weniger gerade gezeichneten Linien zu landen. Wir sind ja wahnsinnig schnell. Die brauchen einen langen Bremsweg. Hier mit den Gummireifen. Wackelig, und dann ganz wackelig. Und dann steigt auch so Rauch auf. Und das ist wahnsinnig. Da müssen die Aliens auch anschnallen und wir hinsetzen kurz vorm Landen. Und dann müssen die Sätze hochgeklappt werden und die Tischchen vor einen hochgeklappt werden. Klar. Aber wurde dir das wirklich so erklärt oder ist das eher so ha ha ha lustig, da gibt es Leute? Nee, das ist ha ha lustig, das haben die einfach gemacht, um die Götter anzufliehen.
Und die dachten, die Götter hätten Bock auf lange Striche oder was?
Ja genau, also die haben dann so Fruchtbarkeitsrituale und so gemacht und den Gott angefläht, damit es endlich mal wieder regnet und haben dann so lange so große Symbole reingezeichnet und diese Linien, glaubt man, kommen einfach davon, weil da mal Bauwerke entstehen sollten oder die vielleicht einfach so in so ganz Gänsemarsch da lang gelaufen sind. Und das ist wirklich beeindruckend, weil die sind uralt, die sind zu 3000 Jahre alt, diese Bilder. Und da muss ich sagen, Respekt, vor 3000 Jahren gemacht, ist immer noch da, coole Sache. Nicht so cool, sorry, zwei von fünf Sterne Inka, die Inka sind nicht so cool, die waren dafür, dass sie das erst im so 14, 1500 war, da kann man schon ein bisschen weiter sein. Also in deinen Top drei der südamerikanischen Ureinwohner. Maya auf Platz eins. Aktuell noch Inka auf Platz zwei.
Wir wissen noch nicht, wo die Aztik...
Die Nazca sind auf Platz zwei.
Ganz anders, viel früher.
Moment mal. Du glaubst, Südamerika ist Inka, Maja, Azteken. Bis jetzt war mein winziger Geist, mein winziger Horizont. Sorry, pardon. Also das tut mir leid, aber da muss man mal nach Südamerika reisen. Okay. Dann nimmst du meinen Rucksack in die Hand. Bitte erklär mir die Welt, bitte. Nascar, aber hat das was mit dem Rennsport zu tun? Nein. Gut. Also es gibt vier. Maya, Nazca, Azteken, Inka, Ultraviele. Tausende. Kleine Untergruppen und alles. Genau. Die Nazca war so 600 vor Christus an. Und du findest jetzt die Nazca aber besser als die Inka?
Ja, weil die länger, die haben mit weniger Aufwand etwas Nachhaltigeres gemacht.
Die haben drei Inka auf zwei Nazca auf eins Maya.
So, okay, sehr gut.
Gut, dann haben wir es doch jetzt.
Ja, nee, das ist nicht so.
Mein Gott.
Aber ich glaube, es braucht eine Harald- Lesch-Azteken-Doku.
Die Azteken, todbringendes Volk.
Wo waren sie und was haben sie getrieben?
Bei jedem Inka-Bauwerk gedacht, habe ich mir diese Stimme vorgestellt.
Die Inka, die Überreste sind spärlich, harmloses Bauernvolk oder todbringende Aliens?
Todbringende Aliens.
Machu Picchu, geheimnisvolle Stadt in den Anden.
Hat man hier einfach nur gewohnt oder Kontakt zu Ausserirdischen hergestellt?
Das sind die Fragen, die man sich stellt.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum diese Völker so anfällig sind für diese UFO-Verschwörungstheorien.
Ja, schwierig, aber ...
Bei Neuschwanstein sagt keiner, oh, das waren Aliens. Das war auch eine schöne Verschwörungstheorie. Der Eiffelturm, Entschuldigung, es ist offensichtlich ein Leuchtturm für Aliens. Ja, wirklich. Das Röste war in der einen Stadt, wo wir länger waren, Cusco, die ehemalige Hauptstadt der Inka, wurde der Markt, die Markthalle von Gustav Eiffel gebaut. Was? Dem Eiffelturm. Der Eiffel. Architekten. Und da haben die das so gesagt, das ist einfach eine sauhässliche Halle. So richtig hässlich, wo ich dachte ... Wahnsinnig hoch und dünn, ne? Auch völlig unpraktikal. Guter Witz. Danke. Aber falsch. Aber hier, mein Neugefunder ernst. Wenn es um die südamerikanische Kultur geht, dann verstehst du auch keinen Humor mehr. Ich habe zu mir gefunden, stellst du dir heraus, ich bin ein wahnsinnig ernster Mensch. Ja, okay. Aber ich habe dann die Markthalle angeguckt und die war einfach brutal hässlich. Und dann hat man so gedacht, wie früher dann so die Leute aus Kusto angerufen haben, bei dem berühmtesten Architekten der Welt, Gustav Tienes Tiempo, hier unsere Markthalle zu bauen. Und er hat das gar nicht, das hat gar nicht in den Terminkalender gepasst. Aber er hat es noch irgendwie mit so einem Azubi dazwischen geschoben und hat dann so ein hässliches Ding gebaut. Und die waren auch so, ja, okay. Ach scheiße, das war heute?
Ja, fuck. So sah das aus.
Peruanische Halle.
Basti, mach mal kurz irgendwie
so ein
was Hallenartiges. Ja, so eine Halle,
und dann drehst du einmal um und dann sieht es schon cool aus.
Und dann irgendwie mit vielen Verstrebungen
oder verschiedenen Ecken. Genau.
Ja, und so Leuchten oben drauf
und so und romantisch und so. Los, komm, kriegen wir schon hin. Ja, okay. So sieht es halt aus. Er wird hier hingeschissen, tat mir ein bisschen Leid für die, um Kuss Kenia. Ja, schon ein bisschen ist auch so ein One-Hit-Wonder-Eifel, oder? Ich weiß nicht, was der sonst noch so rausgehauen hat, aber... Er hat wohl viele in Südamerika gebaut, aber alles da hat er sich keine Mühe gegeben und nur in Paris, le Paris hat er sich Mühe gegeben. Verstehe, na gut. Ja, freut mich, du hast dich neu gefunden, du bist ein neuer Mensch, ein neuer Typ. Ja, ja, das kann man so sagen. Ja, nee, wirklich, also ich erkenne dich kaum wieder. Das ist der Poncho, glaube ich. Tatsächlich viele Leute mit Poncho, die umgelaufen. Und viele Alpakas, oder? Also in der Macho Picchu leben auch primär Alpakas. Da leben Lamas. Ach, Lamas, okay. Ein Königreich lag ich schon wieder direkt daneben. Ja, ist langsam peinlich ein bisschen. Ich weiß langsam, wie sich Leute fühlen, die einen Podcast hören, die wirklich was über das Thema wissen, während wir rumbullshitten. Aber warum hält man Lamas? Also isst man die auch oder nur wegen der Wolle? Ja, es gab sehr viel Alpaka-Fleisch überall. Wirklich? Halsfleisch? Oder was isst man vom Alpaka? Alles. Die essen wirklich alles. Alles? Ja, das bin ich traurig. Also Alpaka sind lächerlich süss. Wir können ja bei der von Lied von singen. Ja, Alpaka sind süss, Alpaka sind süss, sie sind durch, lausche ich und lang ist Hals, und ich fäng dran. Genau. Aber wir können ja wirklich ein Lied von singen, und das zieht sich einfach durch. Sie haben so ein lustiges, flauschiges Fell, riesige Augen mit ganz langen, tollen, runden Wimpern. Und dann gucken sie einen niedlich an, und dann guckt man jedes Restaurant und alle haben Alpaka-Freischaft der Karte. Ich glaube, Alpaka-Schlechter ist der schlimmste Beruf der Welt einfach, wo du immer so 20 Minuten weinen musst, bevor du das Beil rausholst. Wie Zwiebeln eigentlich. Alpakas zu töten ist wie Zwiebeln schneiden. Man weint, während man das tut. Weil die so einen beissenden Gestank haben. Die Armen! Ja, die essen die total, alles essen die von denen. Aber naja, das ist Circle of Life, isn't it? Weitere nicht. Eher eine Linie mit einem klaren Ende, ne? Also, Schlachtung ist eher ein klares Ende, da geht es dann auch nicht weiter. Eher Start und Ziel und auf der Mitte ist ein Messer, wo die sie getötet. Formziel. Ja. Ja, muss man sagen. The Line of Life. The Circle of Life aber mit dem Restaurant, wo man einfach Löwen tötet. Finde auch nicht schlecht. Ja, aber die laufen da überall rum, sind niedlich, werden gehalten, aber Fotos mit denen in der Innenstadt kosten fünf, soll es. Ja, ich war mit Freunden am See und habe Zelda Breath of the Wild gespielt. Ja, habe ich auch gespielt. Das kenne ich auch. Ach so, das hast du auch, okay. Aber ich bin nur bis zum Elefanten gekommen, weil das fand ich so schwer. Ja, der war schwer, ja. Ich fand den Sturmboss dann noch schwerer, da hänge ich auch ein bisschen dran. Ja, hab ich noch gehört, dass der ... Da habe ich ein bisschen Bananen gesammelt davor. Hast du auch in die Komplettlösung geguckt oder so? Nee, ging so. Ich hatte Ich hatte Zeit, ich habe heute eine Woche am See, wir zelten da immer so ein bisschen. War da irgendwie ein Museum oder so? Nee, nee, nee. Ich war einmal im See kurz. Okay. Da ist so ein Baum, ein kompletter Baum ins Wasser gefallen. Ist viel sympathischer. Ich würde mich lieber mit dir unterhalten, als mit jemandem, der drei Wochen in Peru nicht aufhören kann, von diesem Maya-Scheisse. Ja, und es ist immer korrigiert. Inka übrigens. Eigentlich hat er Tatafel, Lamas, eigentlich Alpaka, eigentlich ist es Chicharron. Ja, nobody cares. Nee, weil da ist ein kompletter Baum in den See gefallen. Ach so, darüber wollte ich jetzt aber auch nicht weitersprechen.
Kennst du das immer, wenn man Leute abwirkt?
Ja, gern.
Weil die Bäume fallen alle in den See irgendwann,
aber es gibt immer noch Bäume am See.
Das ist die Frage, die du stellen willst?
Ja. Ich habe gesagt,
die haben drei Wünsche, die haben seit einem drei Fragen
Zeit, ich kann ihnen alle Fragen beantworten, und du willst
fragen, warum es immer noch Bäume an dem See gibt, weil die alle reinfallen in den See? Ja. Was ist die Antwort? Naja, weil der Wind wieder reinballert. Okay. Meine zweite Frage ist, warum macht man nicht einfach alle Joghurtdeckel so, dass die nicht abreissen, wenn man die aufmacht? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, bei manchen so Aktimälder reißt es nie. Das ist so ein dickeres Plastik. Aber warum macht man das nicht einfach bei allen Joghurtbechern? Kosten können. Ah, okay. Was wäre wirklich eine Frage, die du stellen würdest, einem Genie? Warum werden Fenster dreckig? Also welche Art von Dreck kommt also von... Regen ist nicht nur Wasser, okay? Regen sind auch andere Schwebstoffe. Ah, ich verstehe. So ein Typ, der einfach alles hätte googeln können. Und dann wieder zurückpilgert, den ganzen langen Weg auf diesen schnee verhangenen Gipfel. Die ganzen 5322 Meter des Machu Picchu wieder runter. Ich verstehe, warum es aussen schmutzig ist, aber nicht verumsangenen Gipfel. Die ganzen 5.322 Meter des Machu Picchu wieder runter.
Ich verstehe, warum es
aussen schmutzig ist, aber nicht warum es
also innen, was kommt davon?
Es ist einfach Staub, was an der Fensterscheibe hängen bleibt.
Ach so,
das war die vierte Frage.
Dann habe ich keine Fragen mehr.
Dann fiel ich bei dir auf den 23
beschwerlichen Tagen runter.
Ciao, ich bin glücklich. Ja. Ich bin froh, ich bin neu erholt. Aber du hast recht, man freut sich wieder auf den Alltag, man freut sich wieder auf Europa. ÖPNV? Auf ÖPNV kriege ich immer nicht hin. Wenn ich das versuche abzukürzen, kriege ich es immer nicht so schnell hin. Öppentlicher Nahverkehr. Ja, genau. So merke ich mir das auch. Öppentlicher Nahverkehr. Niemand freut sich wirklich auf sowas. Und du hast dann, es gibt ja viele YouTube-Kanäle oder so, die wöchentlich veröffentlichen. Und dann kommt man nach dem Urlaub zurück und hat zwei Folgen auf Halde und kann die direkt angucken. Und dann sind auf Netflix neue Sachen ausgekommen, diese Woodstock-99-Doku, die ich angeguckt habe. Toll, spannend, da ging ja viel Schieb.ief. Florentins Filmtipp? Ja. Es ist wie Fire Festival, nur 99. Genau, Woodstock-99 ist toll, ist toll, da konnte ich gar nicht, da ging eine Menge schief. Ne, aber ich kann damit sehr relaten und bin traurig, dass ich derjenige sein muss, der von seiner unangenehmen Selbstfindungsreise, es war ja keine Selbstfindungsreise, ich würde mir einfach zwei Leute besuchen. Hast du dich verloren? Ich habe mich verloren. Ich würde mich ehrlich gesagt lieber selber verlieren, als mich selber zu finden. Aber sagt man das nicht so, verliert man sich nicht bei erholsamen Urlauben und findet sich auf so Abenteuerscheiß? Ja, ich glaube, du brauchst eine Mischung aus sich verlieren und sich finden. Du verlierst dich in der Tätigkeit, aber dann musst du dich auch danach wieder finden. Es fing schon beim Flug an, da bin ich sehr aufgeregt, weil alle diesen scheusslichen Film im Flugzeug Uncharted geschaut haben, diese Videospielverfilmung, und alle im Flieger, man kann ja quasi auf alle Bildschirme voreingucken, und alle haben den geschaut. Zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt auf diesem sehr langen Flug haben alle Uncharted geguckt. Und an diesem einen Punkt waren zwei Leute vor mir und ganz vorne der war schon ganz am Ende. Und vorne mir die Frau war noch am Anfang. Und ich konnte den Anfang dieses scheuslichen Films und das Ende dieses scheuslichen Films gucken und wollte der Frau, die am Anfang war, zurufen, guck mal vor dir, was da gleich noch für eine Scheisse passiert. Guck mal, was die jetzt machen. Drehen Sie sich mal ein bisschen um und gucken Sie mal auf dem Bildschirm vor sich, was für eine Scheisse da am Ende. Das ist eigentlich sehr luxuriös, dass du direkt sehen kannst, lohnt sich das noch, den anzugucken oder nicht. Das ist das Finale des Films. Guck, was die machen. Und dann können sie sich einfach aufhören und sich diesen Schwachsinn ersparen. Es ist so ein bisschen wie 3D, nur mit Zeit. Es ist eigentlich 4D. Also wenn du einen 3D-Film sozusagen alle Frames gleichzeitig sozusagen siehst oder alles nebeneinander laufen, dann ist es eine 4D-Erfahrung, weil du sozusagen die Zeit auch mit eingedrückt hast. Ist nicht ein 4D-Kino, haben wir es gerade gelöst, ist nicht ein 4D-Kino einfach ein riesengroßes Daumenkino, wo, wenn man sich einmal umdreht, der ganze Film mit Post-its, mit so kleinen Fotopost-its aufge... Nee, 4D ist ein 3D-Kino, wo dir Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt wird. Ach ja, stimmt, wo man diesen Wackel sitzt. Die vierte Dimension ist Wasser. Okay, pass auf, dann ist die fünfte, also ein fünfte Kino wäre, der ganze Film läuft zu allen möglichen Zeitpunkten des Films, also wir brauchen 24 Frames per Sekunde mal die Anzahl der Sekunden des Films, kleine Bildschirme, die um uns herum einmal laufen, wenn man sich 360 Grad im Raum dreht. Du sitzt währenddessen auf einem, den kannst du selber einstellen, drehbaren.
Warum muss sich dann der Stuhl drehen? Du kannst doch dann einfach.
Ja, du musst ja, wir brauchen ja noch diesen Wackelstuhl, der Wasser ins Gesicht spritzt.
Ach so, okay.
Und du kannst dich drehen auf einem Wackelstuhl, der Wasser ins Gesicht spritzt.
Aber eigentlich müsstest du ja alle Zeiten gleichzeitig sehen können.
Genau, genau. Ach so.
So dass du eigentlich eine Leinwand aufgeteilt wird, in wie viele Sekunden so ein Film hat, Menge, und die siehst du dann alle gleichzeitig. Und dann hast du sozusagen eine zeitübergreifende Filmerfahrung. Ja. Also jeder Pixel ... Meinst du, das wird sich durchsetzen für die, weil das ist recht schnell. Du hast in relativ kurzer Zeit den Film durch. Ich habe mal diese sehr unterhaltsamen Wackelstühle mit dem Wasser ins Gesicht spritzen, die haben sich schon nicht durchgesetzt. Ja, das stimmt. Jetzt glaube ich nicht, dass wir mit unserem wissenschaftlichen Was-ist-wirklich-5-D-Kino-Anspruch da durchkommen. Ich glaube, das ist doch das Letzte, was du als Filmemacher willst, dass du einen Film auf dem Flugzeug angeschaut hast. Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe mal gehört, dass im Flugzeug keine Filme laufen dürfen, die Szenen von Flugzeugabstürzen oder so im Film haben. Oh, aber ein Schadensamt-Flugzeug-Abstürz. Ach, wirklich? Okay. Spoiler. Aber ist es vielleicht so ein Propeller-Flugzeug, das man nicht assoziiert mit dem, in dem man sitzt? Nee, so ein Frachter. Weil ich dachte mir, ob nicht so krasse Regisseure, so ein Kubrick oder so, dann extra einen Flugabsturz einbauen in den Film, um zu verhindern, dass es nicht im Flugzeug läuft, sondern die Leute es im Kino anschauen. Ja, ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert, weil man will ja zum einen auch, etwa wenn das im Flugzeug läuft, heißt ja, es hat so großen kommerziellen Erfolg. Nein, aber kein Mensch schaut einen Film im Flugzeug und sagt, oh, jetzt freue ich mich auf den Film, endlich den neuen Kubrick, den nehme ich jetzt so auf, wie der Macher sich das gedacht hat. Man versucht Zeit rumzubekommen. Ja genau, Zeit totzuschlagen und möglichst währenddessen einzuschlafen, das ist das Ziel. So willst du nicht, dass er in den Film geschaut wird. Stimmt schon, am Anfang steht immer, dieser Film ist nicht dafür gemacht, in diesem Flugzeug zu laufen. Der ist für die große Leinwand gemacht, für zu Hause ein Heimkino, aber nicht für diesen Drecksbildschirm, steht dann da auf dem Bildschirm, wo ich mir denke, der arme Bildschirm, der kann am wenigsten dafür, der kann nichts dafür.
Ich bin so groß, wie die Lehne ist, ich kann nicht grösser sein und ich bin so tief, wie dieser Schitz ist, andernfalls hättest du zu wenig Beinfreiheit, ich bin ein kleiner Flugzeugbildschirm. Und ich muss so eine dicke Scheibe vor mir haben, weil Kinder die ganze Zeit auf mir rumdrücken und auf mich rumhämmern.
Ich bin in der Kette von Verantwortlichen, der am wenigsten schuldig ist. Und ich muss so eine dicke Scheibe vor mir haben, weil Kinder die ganze Zeit auf mir rumdrücken und auf mich rumhämmern.
Ich bin in der Kette von Verantwortlichen, der am wenigsten Schuld hat.
Mhh, Dune.
Dieser Film ist nicht dafür gemacht, auf mir zu laufen.
Ich bin zu schlecht für Dune.
Aber jetzt viel Spass mit dem Film.
Warner Brothers Studio. Guck mal, wie Timothy Sharamay guckt. Und erwischt oder nicht, getroffen? Ja, geht's. Hollywood ruft mich an, wenn Timothy zu teuer ist. Ich hab Zeit. Ich hab wirklich Zeit. Du hast die gleiche Frisur, das passt schon mal. Ja. Du hast die Augen weit aufgerissen und den Mund auf. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum. Ich hab mich neun Tage lang nicht gekämmt. Und es ging. Ich mich auch nicht. Ich sah besser aus tatsächlich. Ungekämmt? Ja, ungekämmt sah man besser aus, weil da verfilztes Haar so zusammen und es hat so ein bisschen mehr Struktur und ist nicht so flatterig irgendwie so. Dann hat es wie so einen Helm. Die perfekte Frisur ist ja wie so ein Lego-Helm, so eine Lego-Frisur, die du so in einem Stück aufsetzt, die so gar kein Eigenleben hat. Du sagst bei, das ist die und der ist die perfekte, häufig Lego danach. Ja, das stimmt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du weißt. Gut, dass du es nochmal ansprichst. Das ist nicht die Norm. Lego ist nicht die Norm. Lego ist eine Abstraktion der Wirklichkeit. Du willst keine Frisur haben wie das Lego-Männchen. Ja, weil wenn du halt diese Noppen hast, dann kannst du alles halt direkt draufstecken. Also wenn der Tisch, wenn der jetzt so Noppen hätte, könnte ich meine Kaffeetasse so direkt draufstecken, ohne dass sie runterfällt. Verstehst du? Weil das ist doch viel besser, wenn alles, was du hast, so Legonoppen hat. Ja. Ja. Du hast völlig recht. Warum ist nicht alles mehr wie Klemmbausteine? Aber stellst du dir jetzt einen Tisch vor, der so kleine winzige Lego-Noppen hat, oder die hochskaliert sind, dass so ein ganzer Tisch so sechs Noppen hat? So dass halt genau meine Kaffeetasse mit diesem vorgefertigten Klemmding genau auf einen so ein Ding passt. Ja. Wie stellst du dir vor? Ich hab mir jetzt so sechs grossen Noppen vorgestellt. Genau, ich meine auch. Sechs riesige Noppen. Und du hast halt eine sehr grosse Kaffeetasse. Das Problem ist halt, mein Stuhl hat ja auch dann eine grosse Noppe. Und wir sind nicht so gebaut. Ja gut, ein Stuhl ist eine grosse Noppe. Das stimmt. Oder nicht? Und man setzt sich dann eigentlich, naja, nee, Lego-Männchen haben ja hinten auch im Ärschchen so ein kleines, so ein gross Loch und dann passen die genau auf ein so ein Ding. Oder nicht? Ja, kann schon sein. Ich kann auch meinen Lego-Luke Skyward in meinen X-Wing setzen. Warum kann ich den in meinen X-Wing setzen, hätte er auch einen Noppen. Ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Naja, aber ich verstehe, was du meinst. Der Rest müsste halt so sein. Wenn man wenn man Häuser baut und diese typischen Steine, warum die nicht oben noppen haben, ist für mich auch ein großes Thema. Das weiss ich auch nicht. Vielleicht Copyright-Schwierigkeiten? Ich habe gehört, Lego ist da ziemlich geizig. Das wäre mal cool, wenn die Inka das gemacht hätten. Wenn die mit so riesen quasi Lego-Vorstein, wenn das so ein Lego-Volk wäre, mit so Klemmtechnik. Aber nein, nein. Und dann, wenn sie so ein Gebäude abreißen müssen, dann haben sie dieses große Trending, so diese, diese große Hebel, mit dem sie alles wieder aufhebeln können. Und so eine große Plastikbox, wo man dann die Steine reinmacht, nach Farbe sortiert. Und ein so ein riesengroßes Papierheft, wo so fünf Leute umblättern müssen, wie sie ihren Tempel bauen müssen. Fünfzehn, wir waren doch erst bei vierzehn. Ah, verdammt, wir haben das falsch gemacht. Nochmal zurück. Ach, auf rechts, ich habe das Video verkehrt. Lego-Fölkchen. Ja. Ja, das war, anscheinend zu gucken, das war horrormässig, wirklich, es war wie so eine Personal Hell. Ich dachte erst, ich träume und wache aus meinem Albtraum auf,
aber nein, es war die Wirklichkeit.
Alle haben den Film geschaut und ich habe den auf allen Bildschirmen zu einer anderen Zeit gesehen.
Ich finde, du bist ein bisschen zu hart zu dem Film.
Nicht, dass Tom Holland jetzt gerade zuhört und eine Träne verdrückt und sich denkt, Mensch...
Tom, verstehe mich nicht falsch, du bist natürlich wie immer a gem, a hidden gem,
not so well, national treasure.
Du bist eine national treasure, die beschützt werden sollte, auf alle Kosten. Auf alle Kosten. At all costs. Du willst Tom Holland auf alle Kosten verteidigen. Tom Holland is a national treasure and has to be protected. Okay. Und wir müssen ... At all costs. Okay. Ich nehm es nicht. Du scheust wed münchen ... Sternchen? Ich möchte mich selber nicht in Gefahr bringen. Okay. Okay? Ich zahle 100 Euro. Ich zahle ... Wenn mich das ... Ja, maximal darf mich das 100 Euro kosten. Ja. Und ich möchte mich nicht körperlich in Gefahr bringen. Und auch ungern reisen. Mein Terminkalender darf davon nicht beeinflusst werden, zum Holland zu beschützen. Meine Füsse sehen jetzt aus wie Birkenstocks, weil ich habe acht Tage lang Birkenstocks in der Sonne getragen. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt genau diese Birkenstockform direkt auf den Füssen. Also ich würde sagen sexy. Hot, hot, hot, hot, hot. Hot, hot, hot. Also für alle, die mich in der Öffentlichkeit barfuß sehen, glaube ich, da gibt es kein Halten mehr. Aber hast du deine Pediküre da angepasst? Also bist du ein bisschen penibler geworden beim Fussnebel schneiden? Nö. Ich denke mir immer so, die beste Marketingidee für Birkenstocks wäre so die Stockenbirgs, dass du so Schuhe hast, die genau invertiert, die die Bänder haben, sodass du die erste Hälfte des Urlaubs die Birkenstocks und dann die Stockenbirgs trägst und danach dein Fuss genau gleichmäßig gebräunt ist. Perfekt. Problem, du hast keine Sohle. Gut, naja, die Sohle von unten kommt jetzt in der Regel keine Sonne. Oder legst du dich in die Sonne und streckst die Beine so hoch, damit du auch die Sohle bräunst? Jemand hat mir erzählt, dass er an den Sohlen Sonnenbrand hatte, was das Schlimmste der Welt ist. Und viele Fragen aufwirft. Weil die meisten Stellen, die Sonnenbrand bekommen, machen wir uns nichts vor, berührt man dann nicht so häufig, sonst hätten die auch kein Sonnenbrand, dann tut es ein bisschen weh, aber du hast nicht diesen Druckschmerz. Wenn deine Fusssohlen hingegen Sonnenband bekommen, ätzend. Und der läuft auf Spiegeln den ganzen Tag. Oder wie läuft das? Ich meine, der hat so gelegen wie so eine Katze, die so alle Viere in die Luft streckt. So eine umgekippte Katze. Wie so ein Legomännchen auf dem Rücken, oder? Ich weiss wieder nicht, wo dieses Lego-Ding kommt, aber ja genau, und, also gut, dann lassen wir die Sohle, aber der Rest wäre dann invertiert, der Rest wäre jetzt vorne wie so Crocs. Ja, genau, der die Zehen so überdeckt. Und es wäre genau richtig, dann könntest du es genau komplementär machen. Wollen wir Stockenbergs an den Markt bringen? Heisst das Podcast-Ufo. Ja, wir revolutionieren den Schuhmarkt, könnte schon funktionieren.
Die Hälfte, die andere Hälfte.
Ja.
Vor allem, die sind ja einfach zu produzieren, weil das ja das, das weggeschnitten wird in der Produktion von Birkenstock. Wir müssen uns eigentlich nur in die Birkenstock-Fabrik schleichen.
Und in den Müll.
Wir entsorgen für euch den Müll.
Birkenstocks, wohin mit eurem Müll?
Gebt ihn uns.
Wir haben eine Idee, nachhaltiger zu sein.
Schickt ihn an Heavy German Shit in Berlin. Wir holen ihn dort ab. Finde ich genial. Finde ich super. Richtig gute Idee. Aber du hast jetzt einfach so ganz tolle weisse Streifen. Ich habe jetzt richtig tolle weisse Streifen an den Füssen. Und ich finde es immer spannend, wie das dann auch verschwindet nach einer Zeit. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, so nicht, mein Lieber. Ich wollte kurz an den Tisch gucken. So nicht, mein Freund. Und ich finde es immer spannend, dass das dann auch verschwindet und danach wieder gleichmäßig ist, so, also dass das gar keine Spuren hinterlässt, dass das nicht so, also dass es nicht gleichmäßig sich wieder reduziert in Farbe, sondern da, wo das Braun ist, sich wirklich wieder reduziert, dass davon nichts übrig bleibt und am nächsten Sommer wirklich wieder bei Null anfängt, so. Also das der, ich nehm mir, lass das doch einfach da. Haut schützt sich, aber vergisst, dass er sich schützt. Vergisst es total und jeden Sommer aufs Neue. Oh, Sonne, what the ... Hilfe, was ist das noch nie gesehen? Ich bin eine neue Hautschuppe. Was ist für ein gleißender Feuerball am Himmel? Lächerlich. Ja, lächerlich. Absolut lächerlich. Das stimmt schon. Und komplett zerstochen. Ich bin komplett zerstochen. Also beim Campen ist es bei mir oft so, ich habe so einen Punkt, also am Anfang verteidigt man sich ja noch gegen Fliegen und Mücken.
Aber du zähltest, ne? Ja, ja, ja. Zähltest. Ja, ja, das ist kein Camping. Wir hatten auch zwei Kühlschränke dieses Jahr dabei. Also das hat nichts mit Campen zu tun. Aber so am Anfang verteidigt man sich noch gegen Mücken und dann hat man so diese scheiß Fliegenfalle und diese Klebespur und die Räucherstäbchen und irgendwie dann das, was man so in die Steckdose anstecken muss und Fliegen klatschen und elektrische Fliegen klatschen, was das einfach das Lameste ist, wo man anfängt, sich gegenseitig zu schocken, weil das wie so ein Tennisschläger mit so Elektroschockspulen drin und am Ende schockt man nur sich selbst oder sich gegenseitig und die Fliegen lachen sich ins Fäustchen. Und irgendwann denkt man sich, haben auch Angst. Sie lachen, aber auch sichere Entfernung. Ich glaube, so wie ich bei einem Tennisspiel in der ersten Reihe. Ich hätte schon Spaß, aber ich würde mich auch so ein bisschen nach hinten lehnen. Weil ich mir denke, will nicht, dass der mir eine rüberzieht. Will nicht, dass der mir aus Versehen eine rüberwischt. Wie ich beim Zirkus eigentlich. Also ich sitze draußen auf die beste Zeit meines Lebens, war da mit Popcorn rein in der letzten Reihe. Wenn ich aber von dem Clown auf die Manege gezerrt werde, dann habe ich genauso viel Angst wie die Fliege, die mit dem großen Tennis schlägt. Ja, ne absolut. Auch so bei Baseball, wir waren ja auch im Baseballstadion, da wirst du ja mit der Erwartungshaltung reingehen, du kriegst ein Baseball. Interessant, ich bin eher der glashalb leer Typ und gehe nicht mit der Erwartungshaltung rein, dass ich ein Baseball fange als einer von 80.000 Menschen in diesem Stadion. Doch, ich denke mir, wenn ich keinen Ball fange, ist ein schlechter Tag. Egal, ob die Nicks gewinnen oder nicht. Ich denke mir aber auch, wenn ich ihn fange, ist auch ein schlechter Tag. Da gleiche ich mich dann wieder aus. Ja, du kannst viel falsch machen. Du kannst nicht viel falsch machen. Ja. Und da habe ich dann auch gleichzeitig Angst und Vorfreude darauf. Und du bist die ganze Zeit wie so ein Torwart, wo aus dem Nichts plötzlich so ein Ball angeschossen kommen könnte. Ja, du standest die ganze Zeit mit einem großen Handschuh, mit einem, machen wir es nicht so, größeren Handschuh als für deine Größe nötig. Ja, das stimmt. Und standest da die ganze Zeit rum und die Leute hinter dir waren sauer, weil du dich nicht hingesetzt hast.
Das stimmt.
Die Leute hinter dir haben aber auch eine Folge Fargo geguckt, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die in der Position sind, sich zu beschweren, dass du dich nicht hingesetzt hast. Der eine hat die erste Folge Fargo und der andere hat die letzte Folge Fargo geguckt und ich dachte mir, um Gottes Willen, der darf nie auf den anderen Bildschirm gucken, sonst ist er komplett gespoilert. Ja, stimmt, die Frau hätte einfach im Kino, äh, im Flugzeug, hätte nach vorne gucken müssen, wer gespoilert worden war, wie Tom Holland plötzlich das Plot-Device aus der Tasche zieht. Vielleicht hätte sie deswegen einfach so gnadenlos nach vorne gestarrt. Und gerade nicht. Und die ersten Erfahrungen, ja. Und dann auf dem Rückflug habe ich den noch scheuesslicheren Film Dumbledores Geheimnisse geguckt und habe mich so darüber ge... Der hat dir nicht gefallen. habe mich so darüber geärgert, dass ich die ganze Zeit mit dem Kopf geschüttelt habe und mich über diesen dusseligen Film geärgert habe, dass ich kurz dachte, was denken jetzt die Menschen um mich herum, wie ich diesen Film gucke? Ich glaube, die dachten nicht, dass ich den Film schlecht finde. Wahrscheinlich liegt es an mir, weil ich so klein bin.
Du dusseliger Kackpilschirn. Er schüttelt immer nur den Kopf und ärgert sich. Aber ich kann nicht grösser sein, weil die Lehne nicht grösser. Ich kann meinen Drecksbildschirm nicht wenigstens auch geilen Sound machen. Der Sound ist auch scheiße. Nein, die anderen Leute sollen ja nicht gestört werden. Das ist das traurigste Lebewesen der Welt. Das traurigste technische Alle hassen ihn, aber es ist nicht seine Schuld. Es ist ein bisschen sein. Was ist Dumbledores Geheimnis? Was ist sein fucking Geheimnis? Was ist es? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Was ist es? Forgettable Geheimnis. Dass er diese Gedankenstrahlen hat oder was und nie nutzt? Dass er die Gedanken speichern kann. Was war denn noch sein Geheimnis? Das sind ja auch Geheimnisse. Hat er nicht mehrere? Ich will mindestens drei Geheimnisse haben. Er hat geerbt. Er hat allen gesagt, er war Selfstarter, Selfmade. Sein Schlösschen, der selfmade, hat er allen gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, ich hatte erst ein ganz kleines Hogwarts mit nur einem Schüler. Und dann aber jedes Jahr habe ich mich hochgearbeitet und zwei und dann irgendwann kam Hagrid dazu, habe ich meinen ersten Angestellten gehabt, Hagrid und dann drei und dann vier Schüler und dann habe ich mich ganz hochgearbeitet. Mir kommt entgegen, dass ich 600 Jahre alt werde, weil ich mehr Zeit, mich hochzuarbeiten. Und dann stellt sich heraus, nein, ich habe das alles geerbt. Also sein erstes Geheimnis war er geerbt.
Zweites Geheimnis war schwul.
Drittes Geheimnis war, meine ich, dass er mit Grindelwald einen Pakt hatte, dass er nicht den besiegen konnte.
Er war mal mit dem verbündet, wollten die Welt verändern, waren aber nur Jungen verliebt, wollten die Welt zum Guten verändern und dann hat sich Rindewald des Bösen verschworen, er kann aber nicht, kann aber nicht helfen, weil er diesen Schwur hat, jetzt den Guten kann er nicht helfen, den zu besiegen, weil er diesen Blutschwur hat, so und das ging die ganze Zeit so weiter, ich habe nicht, das ist dusselig, ganz doofe, kack, unlustige Dialoge, ich habe den ganzen Kopf geschüttelt. Und ich glaube, viele Leute haben gedacht, ich bin so invested bei diesem Film, dass ich die ganze Zeit es nicht fast nicht sein kann. Ich kann nicht sein, dass er geerbt hat. Ich habe das immer geglaubt. Viertes Geheimnis, der Abschluss in Hogwarts wird nicht international anerkannt. Es ist einfach nur ein Blatt Papier.
Es hat keine Bewandte.
Er hat sich ein bisschen was von den Studiengebühren bei Hogwarts in die eigene Tasche gesteckt.
Sie wissen, was in die eigene Tasche gesteckt.
Ein bisschen mehr als nötig.
Die Diäten der Lehrer sind nicht ganz richtig transparent.
Sechstes Geheimnis. Die meisten Geister, die in Hoggarts leben, hat er selber umgebracht. Siebtes Geheimnis, der älter Stab ist nicht der älter Stab. Er hat sich den selber geschnitzt, er hat sich eine Replik gekauft. Achtes Geheimnis, der Bart ist nicht echt, wollte gerade sagen, Perücke.
Das ist ein langer Film, oder? Also wirklich, also bei Geheimnisse dachte ich jetzt nicht an acht Stück.
Ich dachte achtmal, dass es vorbei ist, weil der Film ist nur Dumbledore.
Harry, ich habe noch ein Geheimnis.
Ja, das ist der ganze Film. Der ganze Film ist, wie er in einem roten Sessel vor einem Kamin sitzt und sagt, aber da ist noch eins, but there is more.
Alle wollen immer schon so rausgehen und die Automusik fängt auch schon an und dann so, stopp.
Ich war neunmal dabei, aus dem Flugzeug auszusteigen.
Ich wollte schon aufstehen, Parkplatz, die Automusik beginnt, Crates beginnt.
Lass uns als erstes aufstehen, damit wir nicht irgendwie die Lobby vollstopfen.
Und er sagt, aber ich habe noch ein Geheimnis. Nasen-OP. Was? Man ist doch irgendwann nicht mehr, man kriegt nicht mehr hin, diese Wut oder das Entsetzen über das... Nein. Wirklich. Zendes Geheimnis. Ich wurde von zwei verschiedenen Schauspielern gespielt. Drei, weil ich keine Lust mehr hatte. Drei. Drei? Klar. Jude Law, der Erste und der Zweite. Wen von den drei Schauspielern respektierst du am meisten? Jude Law. Okay, mhm. Hab ich mir ja fast gedacht. Du bist nicht so der Geheimnisse-Typ. Stephans Geheimnisse ist, glaube ich, ein weniger interessanter Film irgendwie. Bei dir kann man relativ viel an der Oberfläche direkt ablesen. So jetzt. Naja, ich hab das Gefühl... Weil ich den einen die Olle Nummer eins und die blöde Nummer zwei genannt habe. Naja, ja. Bei Sir Jude Law, den ein Name genannt. National Treasure Jude Law. Sir Jude Law. Warum ist Tom Holland kein Sir? Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist eine gute Frage. Darf die Queen vollständig selbstständig entscheiden, wen sie neitet? Paddington Bear, Sir. Homer Simpson, United. United! Ähm, okay.
Warum sagen Sie das so streng?
United! United! Ich will nicht geneidet werden. United! Warum, wenn die Queen so Trump-mässig ist. Nighted, nighted, nighted, you're nighted, you're so nighted, you're not knighted, you're re-knighted, I'm gonna take your knight away, sad. Kann man jemandem das Schwert wieder wegnehmen? Ich glaube, du kriegst kein Schwert, du wirst geschwertet, glaube ich. Kann man jemandem das Geschwertetwerden wegnehmen? Das Sir, ich weiß nicht, das muss man dann, dann muss dann. Kommt das, was ich viel spannender finde, kommt das in den Ausweis rein? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ja? Oder? Sir Eleganis, der muss dann wieder das wieder zurückgeben. You're unknighted. Ja, guten Tag, ich würde gern meinen Ausweis abgeben. Alles klar. Und zwar, Sie sehen hier, ich habe hier den Sir eingetragen. Oh, Sir. Genau, ich wurde entnighted von der Queen das ist jetzt allerdings schon ein paar Monate her also wie gesagt, weil ich hatte ja noch dann ziehen Sie bitte nochmal da eine Nummer das ist die entnighted Nummer da hinten dann ziehen Sie bitte nochmal eine Nummer und fressen Sie bitte in den Wad okay. Zu Herrn Guinness und Herrn Lewis Hamilton.
Ian?
McKellen!
Ach so, Herrn Guinness habe ich gesagt.
Aber okay, der sitzt ja, okay, setzt sich auch zu Ian.
Setzen Sie sich zu Ian.
Aber ich werde die Nummer ziehen.
Na Ian, warum verlierst du den, Sir?
Ich habe Fake News verbreitet. Ich habe den Ballrock nicht gewischt.
Schwierig, ist ein hoher Anspruch, wenn du so einen Sir hast.
Ja, wirklich? Ja, nein. Aber man kann auch Tiere zum Ritter schlagen, glaube ich, oder?
So diese eine Lawinemaus oder sowas, glaube ich, wurde zum Neid geschlagen oder sowas?
Oh, wir haben ein tolles Video zugeschickt bekommen. Ich habe erzählt von den Ratten, die Autofahren, nächste Evolutionsstufe. Ja, die Schlange, die geht. Ja, die Schlange, die geht. Die haben also so eine Art Roboter mit Beinen gebaut und da eine Schlange reingeschickt. Das ist eine Riesenröhre. Du hast es vor, eine dreimittel lange Röhre. Das ist ein Sitz für eine Schlange. Ein Fahrersitz für eine Schlange.
Ja, genau. Aus meinen schlechteren Menschenaugen.
Aus seinen Beinenaugen. Es ist eine
zwei Meter lange
transparente Röhre.
Wie so eine Abwasserröhre.
Für eine Schlange eine bequeme Sitzgelegenheit.
Gern. Und dann hat man
vorne zwei Roboterbeinchen drangemacht und
hinten zwei Roboterbeinchen und man lässt die Schlange
reinkriechen in diese Röhre,
transparente Röhre und lässt die
Vielen Dank. Again, und dann hat man vorne zwei Roboterbeinchen drangemacht und hinten zwei Roboterbeinchen und man lässt die Schlange reinkriechen in diese Röhre, transparente Röhre und lässt die gehen. Und die kann das anscheinend steuern. Genau, ich glaube, die Positionierung des Kopfes vorne zeigt den Beinchen die Richtung an, in die die langsamer als die Schlange sonst wäre geht. Das heißt, die Schlange zieht es vor, mit Beinen zu laufen, als ihre normale Schlängeltechnik. Und vor allem, wie grausam ist das eigentlich, der Schlange einen Tag Beine zu geben und danach die wieder in die Wildnis zu hauen und sagen so, pass auf, jetzt setz dich mal in Schlange. Ich finde, wir sollten jedem Tier Flügel dran bauen, für einen Tag fliegen lassen und dann wieder wegnähen. Und dann mal gucken. Und dann hast du so ein depressives Gürteltier. Einfach, ich werde nicht wieder fliegen können. Warum bin ich nicht weggeflogen? Weil das ist nämlich, glaube ich, das Schlimmste. Wenn diese Art von Tiere in die Wildnis geraten und sich fortpflanzen und dann die Nachfahren auch diese Roboterbeine haben und du das nicht mehr unter Kontrolle hast und irgendein Armadillo unterwegs ist mit Roboterflügeln, dann hast du ein richtiges Problem. Ein richtiges fucking Problem. Gürteltier. Und eine Maus mit Flügeln ist eine Fledermaus. Die denken, fuck, so knapp. Evolutionär so scheisse knapp. Sie sehen Mäuse, Fledermäuse und denken, ach, eines Tages.
Werde ich zum Kokon?
Nee, erst wenn Mäuse, Fledermäuse und Raupen sehen, die sich einkokonieren und zu Schmetterlingen werden. Und dann macht es Klick.
Dann macht es Klick.
Moment mal.
Und dann ist die Enttäuschung riesig, wenn sie sich einkokonieren, nach Winterschlaf rauskommen und immer noch eine scheisse Maus sind. Nicht immer eine Ratte, immer noch eine kleine Kackmaus. Und so Mäuse treffen sich und sagen, sollten wir uns nicht so langsam einkokoniert haben? Also machen wir das von selber oder müssen wir das, also ist das wie? Wie starten wir den Prozess? Müsste ich ja wissen eigentlich, instinktiv müsste ich ja jetzt den Drang haben, Kokon zu bauen. Ja,, vielleicht müssen wir es auch selber machen. Hast du den Drang, Kokon zu bauen? Ich habe den Wunsch. Ich habe auch den Wunsch. Aber nicht den... Aber ich spüre es nicht. Ja, nicht... Er wäre schon cool, aber es ist nicht so... Da fliegt... Es ist Jerry die Fledermaus. Nein, Jerry! Ich sag euch nie, wie ich es gemacht habe. Fling, fucking Jerry. Jerry ist abgehoben. Und wir heben auch ab für diese Woche. Heben für diese Woche ab, sorry für diese. Herrliche Woche, ja, das muss jetzt durch, durch die Dia-Show und da waren wir auf Machu Picchu. Ich habe euch allen die Sieden Pisco mitgebracht, hier waren wir hier, ach nee, das ist nur fast aus Versehen. Du hast mir gar nichts mitgebracht. Du hast übrigens gesprochen, dass du überlegt hast, mir was mitzubringen, was nett ist. Am Flughafen in der Souvenirabteilung kam mir noch der Gedanke, dir was mitzubringen. Man sagt ja immer, der Gedanke zählt. Aber eigentlich ist es nicht. Jeder kann sagen, ich hatte einen Gedanken. Aber gut, vielleicht beim nächsten Mal. Ich habe so viele schöne Gedanken, weil ich denke, der Gedanke zählt. Ja. Wir machen das nächste Woche wieder eine normale Folge, sorry, sorry, mit meinem pretentious Masupizzo, ich habe die Welt gesehen, geblabla. Du hast Tolles erlebt, da muss man auch. Ich hoffe, es ist ein bisschen spannend. Ja, wir machen nächste Woche wieder eine ganz normale, der Puffer-Folge, wo wir Becker sprechen.
Das ist, wie ihr das liebt. Jetzt macht es, du musst jetzt auch nicht so erbärmig bleiben. Wie ihr das liebt, wie ihr uns liebt, wie wir ach so authentisch durch unser Leben wandeln. Ja, das habt ihr dann wieder nächste Woche. Tschüss. Okay, ciao, macht's gut. Nebenab noch. Nebenab!
Es ist eine Worst-Bird-Produktion.